Transcription: Mohand Habchi
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour. Je vais vous raconter
une histoire de sorcière.
Pas la sorcière que vous connaissez
avec son nez crochu,
son balai et ses verrues,
mais une sorcière du Congo.
Cette sorcière, c'est moi,
et mon histoire, c'est une histoire
de courage, de force et de foi.
Je suis née en République
Démocratique du Congo,
dans une bonne famille. Oui.
Quand j'étais petite,
mon père était agent dans
une société de mine de diamants.
On vivait dans une grande maison
à Mbuji-Mayi dans la province du Kasaï.
J'allais à l'école et j'étais heureuse.
Ma mère vient d'une famille pauvre,
à cause de cela, la famille de mon père
n'aimait pas ma mère.
Puis un jour, mon père
a perdu son travail.
J'avais six ans.
Il a dit à ma mère d'aller avec moi,
à Kinshasa avec ma sœur
et mes quatre frères.
Il a dit qu'il viendrait nous rejoindre
pour trouver du travail.
En réalité, sa famille lui avait
demandé de se débarrasser de nous.
Quand ma mère a compris,
il était trop tard,
elle s'est retrouvée toute seule,
loin de sa famille.
Elle a dû vendre tout ce qu'elle avait
pour nous faire manger.
Elle avait changé.
Elle avait tellement maigri.
Ma mère a même fait venir
notre grand-mère pour nous aider,
mais nous avions toujours faim.
Alors ma mère a commencé
à nous envoyer chez des amis.
On faisait des kilomètres à pied
pour aller chercher de la nourriture.
C'est comme ça qu'un soir,
je me suis retrouvée chez une dame,
qui m'avait donné
à manger pour la famille.
Mais il était trop tard pour retourner.
Elle m'a proposé de dormir chez elle
et de ne repartir que le lendemain matin.
Durant la nuit, je parlais
dans mon sommeil.
Ça ne vous paraît pas
très grave, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais cette amie a dit à ma mère
que je parlais aux démons.
Et en même temps,
ma mère et ma grand-mère
sont allées demander
des conseils chez des prophètes,
ceux qui représentent dieu.
Elles cherchaient la cause
de tout le malheur de notre famille.
Le problème est qu'elles m'avaient
amenée chez un faux prophète,
et il a été décidé
que c'était moi la cause,
et que j'étais une sorcière.
Les charlatans m'ont parlé
pendant plus d'une heure
pour que j'accepte
que je sois une sorcière.
Il a crié sur moi sans arrêt.
Ils m'ont fait boire cinq litres d'eau
avec des herbes dégueulasses.
Ils m'ont dit de vomir la viande des gens
que j'aurais mangés
dans le monde des ténèbres.
Imaginez-vous la scène ?
Une enfant de sept ans
face à plusieurs adultes
qui crient sans arrêt.
On me tapait même dans le dos
pour faire sortir cette viande.
À un moment donné,
j'avais peur,
et j'étais tellement fatiguée,
[que] j'ai fini par dire oui,
je suis une sorcière.
Je croyais qu'en disant oui,
le mal allait s'arrêter,
mais j'étais devenue
une sorcière malgré moi.
Une fois qu'on m'a nommée sorcière,
c'était impossible
de retourner en arrière.
Ma mère a accepté la situation,
mais ça ne veut pas dire
que ma mère ne m'aimait pas,
et en même temps,
comme la situation
ne changeait pas dans la maison,
sans argent, sans nourriture,
ma mère a décidé de partir
avec sa sœur en Angola
pour aller trouver du travail.
Leur plan n'a pas marché,
et ma mère s'est retrouvée
toute seule coincée en Angola,
sans argent, sans nourriture.
Et finalement, elle n'est pas revenue,
contre sa volonté,
et elle a été forcée
de nous abandonner elle aussi.
On a perdu toute
communication avec elle.
Et on est resté avec grand-mère.
Pendant deux ans, j'ai été
traitée comme une sorcière.
Les accusations,
les cris,
le jeûne forcé,
le piment dans les yeux.
Elle disait que c'était moi la cause
si ma mère n'appelait plus.
Elle pensait qu'elle était morte
et que je l'avais sacrifiée.
Elle a dit à tout le monde
de ne pas m'aider.
De ne pas me parler.
De ne pas jouer avec moi.
Dans mon quartier,
on ne me laissait pas
m'approcher des autres enfants.
J'étais toute seule, j'étais pauvre,
j'avais faim, mais j'étais
surtout pauvre d'amour.
Et finalement, ma grand-mère,
elle m'a chassée de la maison.
Je suis devenue une Shegué,
une enfant de la rue.
Dans la rue,
on est comme des papillons.
Là où le sommeil nous trouve,
c'est là où on dort.
Dans la rue,
on devient des soldats pour survivre.
On oublie la lecture et l'écriture
pour apprendre à se battre.
Dans la rue, j'ai vendu
de l'eau, des arachides,
j'ai fait du ménage,
mais à chaque fois que je voyais
les autres enfants aller à l'école,
je me rappelais des jours
où j'étais heureuse.
Je pleurais.
Je me demandais si un jour
je pourrais sortir de la rue.
Puis un jour,
ma chance a tourné.
J'ai participé dans un documentaire
Kinshasa Kids.
On m'a payée, et j'ai tout de suite
voulu donner cet argent à ma famille.
Car même dans la rue,
dès que j'avais quelque chose,
je passais voir ma famille
pour le leur donner.
Ma grand-mère a pris de l'argent,
elle m'a encore remise dans la rue.
Plus tard,
j'ai entendu parler d'un film canadien
qui se tournait à Kinshasa.
La même personne qui s'occupait
du casting me connaissait,
et j'ai été invitée au casting.
Je me suis retrouvée face
aux regards des enfants riches
qui étaient là en audition,
même si j'avais envie
de me sauver à cause de leur regard,
je suis restée et j'ai tout
donné pour avoir le rôle.
Pour moi, c'était une façon
de changer ma situation.
J'ai eu le rôle principal dans le film.
C'était bien cool.
La production m'a mise
dans une grande maison
où je pouvais manger tous les jours,
et avoir tout ce que je voulais.
Mais malgré tout ce qui
se passait, j'étais triste.
J'en ai parlé à Kim, le réalisateur.
Ma vie était belle,
mais mes frères et sœurs
étaient toujours dans la misère.
Je ne me sentais pas
bien quand je mangeais
en sachant qu'ils avaient faim.
Alors l'équipe et Kim ont donné
de l'argent à ma famille,
et quand [les gens de] l'équipe
sont rentrés chez eux,
ils ne m'ont pas laissée comme ça,
ils ont trouvé une maison d'accueil,
ils ont fait en sorte que
je puisse retourner à l'école,
moi qui en rêvais depuis si longtemps.
C'est là où cette histoire
de sorcière devient un conte de fées.
Le film a eu beaucoup de succès,
et je suis passée des rues de Kinshasa
au tapis rouge des festivals.
J'ai même reçu l'Ours d'argent
en 2012 à Berlin.
Le film a été même nominé aux Oscars,
et aujourd'hui j'ai 18 ans,
et j'ai reçu 18 prix dans le monde.
Les oscars, c'était cool...
mais pour moi,
le plus beau jour de ma vie,
c'est celui pour la première fois,
après des années dans la rue,
je suis retournée à l'école.
S'il y a des enfants dans la rue,
partout dans le monde,
c'est souvent parce que les parents
n'ont pas eu le droit d'éducation.
Comprenez-moi bien,
le problème est profond,
la pauvreté, c'est ce qui amène
le manque d'éducation.
Chez moi, envoyer les enfants à l'école,
c'est un luxe,
mais sans éducation,
on risque de se faire raconter
n'importe quoi par les autres
qui vous disent quoi faire et quoi penser.
Ma mère n'était pas bête,
c'est elle qui m'a appris à pardonner
et comment avoir confiance en soi-même,
mais elle s'est fait
prendre dans un piège.
Vous savez tous que
l'éducation est importante,
mais comment se fait-il
que l'éducation reste ici,
et que l'éducation n'est pas
arrivée dans le village de ma mère
avant ma naissance.
Ce n'est pas cool qu'aujourd'hui,
avec tout ce qui existe
[comme] technologie et d'idées,
ça ne puisse pas se faire.
L'ignorance produit des sorcières.
L'ignorance peut tuer.
Alors, pour chasser des sorcières,
construisons des écoles.
Moi [si] je m'en suis sortie,
c'est parce que j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance et de courage.
Ce n'est pas le cas pour beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont encore dans la rue.
Ils attendent aussi
que leurs rêves se réalisent.
Alors, [c'est] pour cela
qu'il ne faut pas les oublier.
J'ai eu aussi le courage
de quitter Kinshasa à 17 ans,
et aujourd'hui je vis au Québec
dans une famille d'accueil.
Je poursuis mes rêves, mes études,
et je reprends le temps
qu'on m'avait volé.
Je vous parle d'espoir,
de courage et de force.
Je ne veux pas qu'on pleure sur moi.
Je ne veux pas.
Retenez cette phrase si simple :
« Aussi longtemps que le cœur bat,
tout est possible. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)